у нас причин її прилюдно не святий з
поєдинку українських депутатів в інших
волини поправкою та так званих
безвізових законі взр вбули таким ще
т.п.
су паритеті будинку в але з тим же з теж
видайте знову волосово ти і оповідь про ось
ці зміни його дають експерти
більше фахівці чим більше
фахівці з читала законопроекту у
хвала не у last party у верховну раду
you тим більше на перешкодив та малий
важливий вигляд хлине по передніх будинках геть з
той процес затягується верховна рада
по ви буду хвали ти повністю
законопроекти ці бали вузла дженіс
європейським союзом безвізовий режим
друга причина вид формування свиту
шлюб реформа в Україні єврокомісії на
висоті аргумент його буду збудованим
є штуки у довідці моя політична
воля для радикальних земель начебто б
з корупції їм третій парі skoda
європейський щур біженців даблою конфу
панда
шляхом у контексті міні ви даєте ще й
єврокомісія тисячі ви проїжджаючи по de
una і на майю безмовна petrenko збоку
населення людині 3 мг сиру тримав щоб
треба то Україні безвізовий режим і
calibration
ukraine причому у брюсселі даєте відразу
мід ще в цехах зручно причина 1000
україна не викинула домашнє завдання
анни сонячні чорниці
я когось щур біженців щось посилав і не
начебто з тероризмом мисливців я не
показувала бути sireci напряму
з правди за 1 пас або оборот буде
тероризм алое ціни є чому з таким
chevy три дні я на побачення околиця вас
візовий режим ціни послаблення кордону у
а з прийнятим хто подружусь
на будинок до експерти на речі з вигляду
єврокомісії про прелюдія тягти його уроку
even буде позитивним ти зовсім на
означає візи для українців оповідь піти
наступна в руку для хачик праска айвен
теж білянка безвізового режиму мої
стати стимулом для проведення реформ вона
їх імітації